what's up everybody Chad here with
another very quick video lesson food
whoa
today's video lesson is not based on a
TV series but a scene from a really
funny Christmas movie called elf so the
context of the scene is that will
ferrell the actor he is an elf one of
Santa Clauses helpers and he's come to
New York to find his real parents but
all you need to know to understand the
scene is that he is in a shopping mall
and he sees a fake Santa Claus and he
goes crazy so it's a really funny scene
to really learn a lot with this scene
download the power lessons click there
and it's a awesome resource that breaks
down on the vocabulary pronunciation and
cultural references and really really
help your in this fluency so download
the power lesson sit back relax and
enjoy this scene from ELF oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
who the heck are you what are you
talking about I'm Santa Claus no you're
not why of course I am
you're Santa what song did I sing for
you on your birthday this year happy
birthday of course so how old are you
son oh you're a big boy what's your name
and now what can I get you for Christmas
don't tell him what you want he's a liar
let the kid talk
you disgust me how can you live with
yourself just cool it zippy
you sit on a throne of lies look I'm not
kidding you're a fake I'm a fake yes
how'd you like to be dead uh-huh kidding
you stink
I think you're gonna have a good
Christmas all right
[Music]
we talked about breathe talk breathe
talk we talk and what can I get you and
and and what can I get you for Christmas
don't tell him what you want don't tell
them what you want tell them what you
want
don't tell them what you want let the
kid talk
let the kid talk let the kid talk let
the kid talk I feel like to be dead
how'd you like to be dead
how'd you like to be dead how'd you like
to be dead I think you're gonna have a
good Christmas think you're gonna have a
good Christmas I think you're gonna have
a good Christmas I think you're gonna
have a good Christmas who the heck are
you you disgust me
[Music]
just cool it zippy you sit on a throne
of lies you're a fake
I'm a fake you stink mean how can you
live with yourself you sit on a throne
of lies
[Music]
[Applause]
who the heck are you what are you
talking about I'm Santa Claus no you're
not
of course I am
you're Santa what song did I sing for
you on your birthday this year a happy
birthday of course so how old are you
son oh you're a big boy what's your name
and what can I get you don't tell him
what you want
he's a liar let the kid talk you disgust
me how can you live with yourself just
cool it zippy
you sit on a throne of lies
look I'm not kidding you're a fake I'm a
fake how'd you like to be dead huh
kidding you stink I think you're gonna
have a good Christmas
[Music]
you